monday is the Emmys yes like like a
fashion and makeup artists dream um what
do you think we will see on every record
again beautiful uh you know even glowing
luminous skin that's number one I think
we'll see lots of pops of colors on the
lips you know we usually see a lot of
matte lips I think we'll be seeing some
glossy lips on a lot of the stars and
this Emmys as well is this about that
skin if the skin is not beautiful and
perfect and even then everything else
sort of doesn't go well so how do you
get the look at home we teamed up with
number seven beauty brand to find out I
have partnered up with number seven
beauty brand today to kind of show you
one how to master that red carpet
glowing skin today we're gonna be using
the number seven lift and luminate
triple action serum foundation so what
makes this different from just say any
other foundation that you well a few
things so first thing it has an SPF 15
which is always great the triple action
serum itself is a very very popular
product so it's age defying it's good
for your skin it makes the skin appear
more firm also it has a this amazing
thing about it that it doesn't settle
into lines it kind of moves with the
facial expressions this skin is gorgeous
these tools of the trade are available
at Target and now it's time to complete
the look super simple and easy way to
get a beautiful red carpet look at home
[Music]